i was i was reading
every time i read i just can't wait to
tell somebody
like i'm reading a book i'm not even
thinking about the book i'm like
somebody's gonna hear about this
you know what i'm talking about here's
another phenomenon sometimes i earmark a
page in the book that i'm reading and
then i'll unearmark it read a couple
pages but then i get embarrassed to
earmark only two page after two pages
after
have you ever done like i'll just go
i'll just go back to the old one and
just know i'm two pages ahead of that
we haven't started the show yet i'm just
telling you something real
this is all just the let's get to know
each other part this happened today i
was like who do i think is going through
my books going this dummy only reads two
pages at a time
you're the [__] weirdo marshalling my
books
if marshalling my books doesn't get the
show off to a good start i i don't know
what will
so the reason i told you i was reading
is i read about this term called
xenoglossy xenoglossy is a word does
anyone know what xenoglossy is
xenoglossy
i feel like it should come up at the
bottom xenoglossy noun
is the phenomena uh where a child who's
never heard a foreign language just
starts speaking it fluently isn't that
isn't that
that's nuts
it has happened so many times there's a
word for it xeno look i'm not here to
say it's real or fake but somebody
thinks that that happened you got a
little baby and you teach it english and
it's like i want some mimi's which is
what i called m m's when i was a kid
give me some mimi's imagine if that
[__] toddler one day was just out of
nowhere
i would drop kick that baby into a
mountain that you're not my son
a river here you [__]
you goddamn demon baby
you speak italian in my house and i
didn't teach you italian you're [__]
gone
slide that baby into a pizza oven you're
done
evil baby none of this was planned i
just need you here and i needed to find
you
like daniel day-lewis behind the
waterfall